[Music]
welcome back to the AT&T Pebble Beach
pro-am joining us now is jordan spieth
find enough to stop by she gets ready
for his opening round here yeah if your
friends want to go golfing on the
weekend
can you go golfing with your friends on
the weekend and have fun and relax yeah
I can you know a lot of weekends where
I'm leaving that Sunday or Monday to go
to a tournament so I'm normally wearing
my coach or something like that but when
we get weekends off or you know a
two-week break it's a lot of fun I like
going out and messing around and you
know I've got friends that are pretty
good I've got friends that you know have
to have a six-pack and just just to get
through the day so I like either way I
mean I like um playing with them either
way it's fun I normally don't I'm not a
serious I can dial it back and just hit
some shots and have fun but it's kind of
few and far between I like to get away
from the game normally when I'm taking
days off what would you do on a day off
to get away from golf um you play any
other sports you know I love shooting
hoops I love yeah I mean we got
basketball in our family my brother
plays in college and I I've got a hoop
at the house so we'll mess around with
that other than that just get out and do
anything I mean in Dallas we've got
we're in season for a professional
sports team it's greater sixty-five days
a year so get to go to a lot of math
game stars games this time of year
there's some someone's playing at home
pretty much every day so I'm a sports
fanatic and love going to them it's a
rough road ahead right now for the Mavs
and the stars they stars around the
grind
David Cowboys break your heart yeah that
was that was tough I was figured we'd be
talking about that at some point here
perfect job how does it tough that was a
tough one man it's just such a good team
it was such a good team this year but
you have s team you haven't won a title
since you've been born they haven't won
a title right you know I was born in 93
so would they win I get him get him
confused cuz Super Bowls played in the
new year I think they wanted the night
in the year 96 to the 95 season is that
right that right 93 as well okay four
and three so I mean
remember it my dad took me to games
those years but don't remember it he's a
Broncos fan but it was nice of them to
raise me as a Cowboys fan
what if dak Prescott calls and says can
you help me with my golf game oh
absolutely
makes me a lot of fun yeah I mean he
steps up to the plate this year and
delivered it was it was fun it was cool
and Zeke - those guys were just they
just having fun I mean they were
laughing on the sidelines together
smiling and he liked to see that you
know obviously you want the intensity of
Brady when it's when it's time to be
intent but you like seeing those guys
kind of rookies having fun the biggest
stage in sports but do you take anything
from that because Golf is singular you
know you're your own team but to try to
enjoy the moment how tough is it to
enjoy a moment when there's so much
pressure attached to it yeah in golf so
frustrating - because you know you you
know going into the day that you're
going to have some bad swings and you
know it's not you can't be perfect I
mean there's no there's no chance even
even your best rounds you did in a
couple shots or a couple putts you
didn't you didn't mean to hit so it can
be it can be very frustrating but yeah I
can definitely watch other athletes at
the top level on the biggest stages and
when they are so composed you know
unfortunately now I have a chance to
talk to a lot of these athletes I've had
relationships of all these guys and so
very fortunate for that because that's
when you really pick the brain what are
they thinking about what's your
visualization like how they get over you
know tv12 there's the pick-6 and they go
down you know 21 to zero you know what
was he sitting there prime e nigh
praying about you know what was his
visualization for the rest of the game
and I'll have that offered opportunity
to ask him because we get that all the
time on a golf course and a four and a
half hour so definitely take a lot off
those guys try a more fun talking to
Jordan speith what kind of conversations
do you have with Brady we did a cool
deal we're both Under Armour athletes so
we did a cool kind of one-on-one take
actually like three years ago is before
I think I'd one went on tour and you
know he was kind of getting ready to try
and win you know a couple more Super
Bowls in his opinion which he ended up
doing but this is prior to to even two
years ago and just a lot of mentorship
about you know success early on in a
career you know he's in his early too
and wins three Super Bowls and how do
you sustain that how do you keep setting
goals how do you keep trying to get
better and dissect the statistics in
order to to pick a part out what to work
on day to day and it was a lot of that a
lot of mental stuff you know there's
he's just what an incredible incredible
athlete being the greatest of all time
in a sport and this week I'm actually
playing with another the greatest of all
time in this sport that's Wayne Gretzky
so just being around these these
athletes after just being a fanatic
myself you got to kind of pinch yourself
here and there it's pretty cool
who makes you nervous I played with W I
played with 43 we made me nervous he
made me nervous until he just started
cracking jokes on the course it calmed
down Secret Service yeah Secret Service
was now a big help we might a few times
no no they didn't help him honestly he
play so fast he gets to his ball before
the Secret Service could even get there
and I don't have a reputation being the
fastest player but I speed it up when
I'm with him so yeah he I mean he makes
me nervous you guys it's a lot of fun he
lives in the Dallas area we get to play
here and there once you know you were
famous um there one of those moments
where you go oh boy
you know the Masters in 15 just being
the Masters there that's when you start
going to restaurants in New York or you
start going to restaurants and you know
orange City Iowa or wherever I mean
either either place you then get
recognized you know you see the double
take and I I'm not wearing a hat you
know people it's always kind of is that
Hitler like maybe that's and and then
finally they just come up and ask and
but it's cool I mean it's great to see
the impact it has and we certainly have
a responsibility as athletes to do
things right on and off the course
because there are so for us in golf you
know the numbers are down and whatever
we can do to try and get the numbers
back up if we can inspire the younger
generation just by you know just by
taking extra time and doing things it's
easy for us and it goes a long way for
other people and I follow the examples
led by you know Phil by Rickie Fowler
means Ricky's you know a good friend of
mine but he's still five years older
than me
I used to look up to the way he handles
things off the course now I'm lucky in
golf that we have this kind of guys golf
can be humbling you know that yeah sure
you find out a whole lot more when you
lose than you do when you win yeah
definitely right yeah I mean 15 things
are rolling we're competing in every
major we won two of them and had a
chance than the other two and won the
FedEx Cup it's just you know you
understand the something new that that's
not normal I mean it's just not possible
in golf you can't do that every year and
then you know I had a heart break this
year at the Masters and then you just
kind of it just it's crazy just the
difference and I feel like in three or
four years on tour I've had what most
people it takes 25 years on tour to have
and experiences and it's good I mean I
could use that to my advantage I think
going forward but you put yourself in
position enough times you're going to
have you're going to have heartbreak and
you're going to have you're going to
have a lot of triumphs as well so can't
win if you're not in in the right shape
to win so that's what we're going to try
and do but explain to me and I read this
and I wanted to ask you it's almost like
you exorcised your demons at Augusta
when you went back to the 12th hole yeah
and yeah and you birdied 12 now this is
in a just a fun practice right was yeah
it was a it was a practice round we had
two groups out at Augusta and when was
this was early December okay mid
probably yeah second week of December
and we went went down 10 and and you
know then we went down 11 we're coming
up and you can see 12 tee boxes the last
time I was there was was was the Masters
and I got on the tee and I could feel
the nerves you know I shouldn't feel no
real time just play but I felt because
I'm like you know what I knew when I got
there I had one mission in that trip and
that was to get up there and knock it on
the green make the putt I hate it over
the bunker had about 15 feet and I hit
the putt and it just barely fell over
the front edge and it was almost like
there's there's a good break we got now
we're back on track I asked the guys my
group you guys know what I did last time
I played 12 in Augusta I made it too you
know and then the next day I went and
actually almost made a wand it landed
right behind it and sucked back kind of
lifts out went to about there
not exactly the same situation but it
was nice to get there and see a couple
good shots and just you know I was over
it I you know I went on in one you know
one three three or four events later
again with just the mindset that it's
going to happen but in it's strange that
you were nervous walking to that into
strange it's strange yeah I mean I
didn't want to be I even had a confusion
that little cocktail did they [ __ ]
down number ten even had a cocktail
walking down ten like alright you know
there's a fun round it's all good and
then yeah it's bizarre you still I mean
honestly it was it was the same every
time I go up to twelve tee box it you
know that time I knew I felt it a little
bit just because I was like you know
we're getting rid of demons here but
every time you go over to eleven twelve
thirteen you play an Amen Corner you
know I'm sure in the same way you get to
get to those holes you know those holes
are special in and they're they're so
unique and you don't get the opportunity
to play them that much and you want to
play well every time you play them so
it's cool what is it about 18 to Pebble
Beach pro-am that makes it different
than anything else you know um you get
this opportunity to play with with
really cool people and people that are
very successful at what they do and love
golf and that it's kind of funny like I
was mentioning before these
relationships that I'm able to have with
whether it's business manner or it's a
sleet's or entertainers it's all because
I can do what they're not very good at
and they can't figure out why okay
seriously that's that's why and that's
what golf does it's such a difficult
sport that once you're able to do it
these other people want to relate to you
because they can't do it if they are so
good at everything else they do and it's
pretty cool I'm sure I soaked it up I
recognize that's why but so be it I get
these experiences but this tournaments
really cool I mean we play long rounds
we get to play three of the three of the
most pristine golf courses in the world
and we get to compete in a PGA Tour
event with just a more kind of fun
atmosphere we've got there and playing
with Jay Cohen for the third third or
fourth year straight I played with
twenty romo and this is that before
these guys I mean they're good at golf
but they're out there having fun they're
asking you questions about now how
you're feeling on you know when you're
in contention like hey are you nervous
right now whatever it's like normally
people will ask you that in the process
but thanks for asking but yeah I'm still
a little bit but they're uh that's just
it's just awesome it's you get to hit
balls on the range next Aaron Rodgers
and Peyton's on the other side Raymond
Ray Romano and guys are cracking jokes
and you see you see a lot of cool things
going on you know it's embarrassing I
played here 20 years ago and I'm putting
that embarrassing or know I'm putting
range fault I'm putting range balls in
my pocket because they were Titleist and
I'm going these our Titleist here take
up yeah yeah I got Jack Nicklaus and a
Ronaldo young new title is Jack Nicklaus
and Nick Faldo on you know bookending me
and they're watching me putting golf
balls in my bag and I'm going again this
is are you kidding me
yeah yeah yeah I mean this is said they
haven't invited me background by the way
they haven't invited me back to play
well the other day yeah oddly enough we
ran out of range balls that year
probably so the other day I was hitting
balls and I play a Titleist a red
Titleist approval in action I was
hitting balls and I was hitting all
blacks and I I was like Michael is you
grabbed the wrong bag and that's not
about that for a second I'm like how
high maintenance is I gotten out here
then I'm up there going we got the wrong
brand new golf balls that were hit
behind when I'm fine hitting you know
beat up yellow balls that's like you
know kind of grew up doing it it's just
like I was kind of slapped in the face
moment he kind of looked at me kind of
weird he's like be serious right now be
like he felt kind of bad so I told him
if I do that again he could flat hey bud
Jordan is great to see you then good
luck next week thanks for we appreciate
it the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]